hey what's up everybody I'm Tiffany
Smith from fandango movie clips we're
here in Anaheim at Star Wars Celebration
and one of my favorite things about
coming to any convention is all of the
creative cosplayers add a little cosplay
with my Leia buns today so let's walk
around and see what fans we can find and
what awesome costumes are here how do
you respond when people say oh that's a
cute teddy bear hug on shop first rate
he totally did
you gotta do indoors
how long do you think it is until we get
a rocket fest movement
eight
oh and I'm sorry commander is insane so
altogether this cosplay only cost about
a hundred bucks your fruit bar chord or
Han Solo stain okay so we're walking
across the floor and I'd like we've have
to talk to Darth Maul trooper absolutely
Walter put the bomb since it's yours
8080 or a deck
sure to be a storm troopers but ok as
you saw the teaser trailer sometimes
stormtroopers a little bit shorter
Oh perfect so we have risen Leia and
Princess Leia
I'm always upgrading every time I see
something that's better I go by my place
what I have I'm always trying to go for
perfect oh my god your cosplay is male
voice be with you there have been some
seriously awesome cosplayer some of my
favorite fried Darth Vader um the Luke
and Han standin of course I mean the
little swim sugar how adorable with me
all right you guys that's it from this
star wars celebration though make sure
you keep it on fandango movie clips to
find out everything that's going on in
the world of movies i will see you guys
next time i'm gonna head and see what
other fun stuff i can get into